and we are delighted tonight to be part
of a participating here with a panel of
four people who I think exemplify in
fabulous ways that challenging of the
reigning assumptions Laura Flanders our
moderator for tonight is the host of
radio nation on air America she is
somebody who talks the talk as well as
walking the walk and she is both
tremendously entertaining and a very
very serious host she's also the author
of Bush women tales of a cynical species
about women in the Bush administration
and is writing a book a new book
actually which is about the progressive
victories in unusual places and what we
can learn and take from them so I'm
delighted to have Laura Flanders as our
host next to Laura we have called
next to Laura we have someone you all
know who's Paul Krugman who is the
writer for the New York Times op-ed page
he's also a professor of economics and
international affairs of Princeton
University
most recently the author of the Great
Awakening in which many of you have seen
but interestingly enough as we were
talking about what the great unraveling
I gave you even more credit he spawned
an entire era
anyway the great unraveling my apologies
but in the night back in 1989 Paul said
that he was writing about inequality in
the book that he wrote called the age of
diminished expectations and really has
been calling attention to this issue for
a long time
major Louie is a wonderful activist
advocate author organizational person
from Boston may major started her work
as a hospital worker and a union
activist at Boston City Hospital was the
first Asian American elected to
president of a Union Local in Boston and
perhaps elsewhere and since 1995 has
been the director for United for a fair
economy and people may know that United
for a fair economy has done just
incredible work on challenging the the
rollback the repeal of the estate tax
really getting even people like Bill
Gates senior and others to speak out
about the need for the public structures
that are supported by the tax dollars
that people pay so made you as the
author of a freak of forthcoming book
called the color of wealth which is
coming out published by the new press
very shortly
and she will be speaking tonight and
last but not least is Jim Lardner who's
the senior fellow at demos on inequality
issues and who is the co-editor along
with David Smith another senior fellow
at demos who is here tonight of
inequality matters generally has been
passionate and articulate in this issue
for the last several years as a writer
for the New York Times Magazine and for
many many other publications and
actually founded a website called
inequality org which has now become part
of the GMOs family so we've got a great
panel tonight I guarantee you you'll
hear some things that you won't hear at
any other point this evening
and so let me introduce Laura Flanders
all right all right thank you everybody
I'm very glad to see you and not that
other guy in front of me tonight I'm
Laura Flanders and I don't know what our
president is gonna hallucinate this
evening but we in the reality-based
community know that uh the state of our
union really is not we don't have a
union we have at this point a tiny
minority who are earning more wealth
than they can reasonably figure out what
to do with and a vast majority who are
working two jobs never seen their kids
and barely making ends meet if they
don't get sick Bill Moyers in his
introduction to inequality matters which
I urge you all to pick up at the end of
this program begins by looking at the
news of the day and being a very
imaginative and creative person I did
exactly the same thing that bill did
this morning and saw the news of the day
which has on front page of the New York
Times in any paper you happen to look
out across the country Exxon Mobil
reporting that it made a record 36
billion last year
larger than the economies of a hundred
and twenty five countries became the
first country company ever to make more
than ten billion dollars in a single
financial quarter they're clearly not
passing on their profits to average
people however the other news of the day
that caught my eye was on the money wire
wages rise by smallest amount in nine
years wages and benefits paid to
civilian workers rose last year by the
smallest amount in nine years now that's
putting it positively because if you
actually read the article you find out
that when inflation is considered
overall compensation actually fell 0.3
percent the first time there's been a
decline since 96 and when you read on
further you find out that this is
actually all good news for the economy
the Federal Reserve is keeping a close
watch on wage pressures given the strong
growth in the labor market in the past
two years they're worried while
increases in the number of people
working is good for the country the
concern at the Fed is that the economy
could be growing so strongly that wage
preciouses pressures will mount and
trigger a rise in inflation but we can't
have that CNN just to reassure everybody
LED off their story this way real wages
are having trouble keeping up with
prices first-line real wages are not
exactly going through the roof who do
you think they're writing for The
Spinners
love to tell us we're divided in this
country red V blue but I've been
traveling around the country that's not
the division that counts the division
that counts is the one that we're
talking about tonight and it is a threat
not just to our union but to our state
that having been said for the sake of
posterity and for everybody watching out
there in the c-span audience and we
Thank You c-span for being here tonight
I want to give people a sense out there
in the country that this is an issue
that people in New York gathered tonight
this night of the State of the Union to
talk about because we want to get our
union in its true sense back people talk
about Patriots I believe we are the
Patriots
here tonight and we want our country
back and we're united in that effort so
thank you velvet floors everybody that
came out tonight we are united to try to
get our state back on some kind of track
we're going to hear briefly from each of
our speakers and then we'll have them
talk with each other and then take
questions from the audience and I thank
you again or for being here we'll start
with Paul Krugman of the New York Times
okay all right I'm gonna be very nerdy
for a little bit here then while I talk
about talk about what what what do we
know and and what do people think about
this growth and inequality and I found
that it's really helpful in in doing
this too well let me just launch it with
her and I'm sorry the the thing I want
to read for our you is is here on my
laptop so I'm actually going to do it
this way so there's there was some a lot
of people you wouldn't think are
concerned about inequality it's
sometimes surprising and so there was
actually a some fairly passionate
discussion of the problem of inequality
from this last summer from of all people
Alan Greenspan somehow I guess somehow
he's finally getting out from under
Enron's spell there and starting to work
and and and he said some things in
testimony which I think well let me read
you some of it and their mind this is
Greenspan speak so I have to read you
some just give you the flavor so he's
saying essentially the 20% or the
skilled management professional what we
find is the production workers average
hourly earnings are rising very modestly
but because of the distribution of the
skilled workers supply and demand what
we're finding that the increase
implicitly in supervisory workers
average hourly earnings is going up very
much more rapidly representative more
I'm sorry say that again all right is if
for the Supervisory workers are 20
percent the Supervisory professional etc
are the more skilled aspects of our
labor force so we are getting a
bivariate income distribution and as
I've said many times in the past for a
Democratic Society this is not helpful
to say the least
and I think that as I have indicated on
numerous occasions I believe that this
is an education problem that requires us
to get the balance of skills coming in
out of our schools to match the skills
that are the and so on
so this actually Greenspan is saying
bivariate income distribution is bad for
a democracy so he is really concerned
is good and he has a story he's saying
that the problem what's what we're
seeing is that the top 20% is doing very
well as basically the people with the
skills the people with the right skills
are doing well and people without which
is the great majority the bottom 80% are
doing badly and that the answer is
education you've got to improve those
skills and it's a good good story good
policy recommendation and it's all
completely wrong that's the important
thing I think that the thing and
understanding the problem we face is
that that's not at all the story that
that's out there in the fence because
it's not an 8020 problem it's it's more
like a 99 one problem the and continue
being a little nerdy here if you look at
the the Congressional Budget Office has
these data that they put together on
income distribution and they go back to
1979 and up to 2003 so I we believe that
by the time the 2004 and 2005 are gonna
be real humdingers of increasing
inequality but it's not we don't have
the numbers yet but anyway just you know
over the period they they cover okay it
turns out that an average family income
goes up about 1/3 over that period now
the great majority of families to get a
lot less than average the median family
is a little over 10% and the bottom
fifth of the income distribution is
actually going backwards but it's it's
that but the average is about 33% now
you might say well it's the top 20% so
we look into the top 20% how are people
doing at the 90th percentile the income
distribution this is a you know we're
getting out to a really small minority
and the answer is 37% increase so
actually right up there at the 90th
they're not getting an increased share
people way up there the top the very you
know 90th percentile richer than 90
percent of Americans are still actually
not their incomes are not going up any
faster than average on the other hand
top 1% of the income distribution we've
got an increase of 129 percent over the
same period and this is if you look at
it we're
not talking the bottom of that top 1% is
is not is doing well but not nearly that
well that's a number that's being driven
by really a few tens of thousands of
people with extraordinary income so we
really are talking about something where
a tiny tiny minority is is driving this
increase in inequality it's a that it's
not it's it's not that the top quintile
the top 20% for is the rest so what does
that tell us it tells us it's not about
education and skills much as we would
like to think that education is the
answer and it's the educate people are
doing well it's just not better better
to be educated than not and people with
college degrees and are being better
than people with without but by no means
doing especially well it's you know
roughly speaking corporate CEOs on high
school teachers I've got about the same
number of years of education they're not
exactly experiencing the same economic
destiny lately the it's also it's not
it's not obviously about globalization
it is true that that international
competition is undermining some of the
traditionally well-paying good
blue-collar jobs and we can you know
this is sort of a factor but that's not
explaining why people at the very top
are seeing this explosion in income and
and by the way it turns out that this is
not a global phenomenon this explosion
of income at the very top it's not
happening at all in the continent of
Europe it's not happening at all in
Japan it's happening in a very minor key
version in Britain but it's basically
it's a uniquely American phenomenon so
it's not it's not just that a global
economy leads to huge rewards at the top
it's something that's happening in
America basically only so what's going
on
what's actually happening why are we
seeing this explosion of wealth and I
think that the basic consensus is that
we don't know the but but there we can
say a few things about it there is
something missed mysterious about
really have to say that it's not the
simple supply and demand stories don't
do it
that's what Vince pan is saying well
we've got an increased demand for high
skill and we're not producing enough
high skill people and that's the story
it's not absolutely not true that that
one at least doesn't work and it's so
anyways is there a increase in demand
for rapacious CEOs and insufficient
supply of them I don't think that's
right one of my teachers the great MIT
economist Robert Solow once said it was
actually about a different issue but
you're saying that that certain issues
of The Economist's always end up in a
blaze of amateur Sociology and I think
to a certain extent that's where we end
up on this you start to ask what's
happened and a lot of the salaah talked
about norms serious researchers talk
about norms that if particularly we we
basically gone back to roughly actually
more than roughly it's almost exactly
the income distribution of 1929 right
now we're sort of great gatsby is back
and but we had this long period after
the New Deal after world war two of a
really relatively egalitarian income
distribution and how did we do that and
the answer seems to be that there were
norms established about what you could
do what you could pay people and those
norms broke down the people who actually
worried about trying to understand
executive compensation literally use the
phrase to describe the limit on it it's
basically CEOs get to a point the the
committee that decides how much the CEO
is paid so what limits you know what
acts there's no market there so what
actually limits it and they said well
they talk about the outrage constraint
and us there was a quite strong outrage
constraint in in the in in the 60s and
and much too much the 70s if a CEO was
paid 40 times what the average worker
was paying the company people say oh my
god that's terrible
these days no being paid a thousand
times doesn't actually raise eyebrows so
now the outrage constraint went away on
why did that happen well at this point
we start to talk about issues of
political power or something we don't
have to sand I'm not going to go too far
in this because we don't fully
understand but we do know that this is
not just the workings of supply and
demand it doesn't seem to actually have
much at all to do with with markets it
has to do with with social norms and
power relationships and something
something snapped in the American system
leading to this explosion of inequality
and just the last thing to say two last
things to say what do you do about it
it's not easy to know how you restore
those norms but one thing you can
certainly do about about income
inequalities you can tax the people with
very high incomes and and try to provide
a stronger safety net for the people
with lower incomes and the remarkable
thing of course about US policy is that
as the inequality has exploded policy
has systematically and increasingly
moved to reinforce the growing gaps the
tax tax rates for the extremely rich
have never been so low and not not since
the 20s and so we've the there's
something going on here which spreads to
the political realm and we're seeing
that the political process which you
would think would be a great uprising of
the the other 99% saying let's soak the
rich has actually been one of
systematically favoring the people who
are gaining from these trends the story
thank you
next lissa from Jim Lautner this trend
this story goes back to the late 1970s
roughly and it kind of slipped in under
the media radar you may recall in the
early 80s there were a lot of articles
about the shrinking serve manufacturing
the the shrinking middle class that
those stories faded pretty soon I recall
that at the time most mainstream
economists and and others dismissed the
idea that there was some kind of major
shift towards greater inequality in
America and then we kind of forgot about
it for a while other stories have always
seemed more important in these last 30
years so so this one has lurked in the
background the people who said it wasn't
happening at all have been allowed the
luxury of now now saying it is happening
without ever acknowledging that they
were mistaken and that it when they said
it wasn't happening and and have now
turned to saying that it doesn't matter
it's a non-issue and they have several
forgive me for using this a day but
there really are quite a lot of these
folks who have written articles and and
given speeches in which they say that
rising inequality does not matter some
go further and say that it's good for us
and one of my favorites was by a guy I
have to mention his name because the
story doesn't make any sense without his
name his name was I think it's Jonah
Berg he's uh was at the time he wrote
this piece of an editor at the National
Review and he posited a country that
consisted of only two people himself and
Bill Gates and this was to explain why
anyone who thought that inequality
you know the relative differences
between the people at the bottom and
those at the top or the people at the
middle and those at the top was
something to worry about was an economic
illiterate or or some you know just
didn't wasn't reasoning properly he said
in this country which he named Gates
Berg eeeh the inequality
would be horrific you know and yet he
went on to say I would be tremendously
well off and he said that was because
basically he would be living off of the
the leavings of Bill Gates he would be
able to shine his shoes he would be able
to who knows what else a whole variety
of personal services for Bill Gates and
and he would be highly paid for them not
relative to Bill Gates but perhaps
relative to what he was earning in this
world this United States and so he would
be much better off in gates burg eeeh
and then he went on to add and just
imagine if Warren Buffett and the Sheikh
of Brunei moved in you know inequality
would be enormous ly worse you know and
and and people will be writing articles
about how I'm being left behind you know
so the whole point was how silly it is
to worry about that stuff we put
together this book with the idea that
after nearly three decades of rising
inequality in America perhaps it was
time to pause and take stock and look at
how it has changed American life in a
variety of ways and I think we weren't
we the people who we had a conference in
June of l4 nearby and and then set to
work on doing this book which is a
collection of essays but kind of a
collection in which we planned it to go
a certain way we all kind of work
together and it's a sort of connected
essay consisting of essays not that
everyone agrees about everything I don't
think that any one of us could have
known or could have sense the
wide-ranging effects that we would find
when we put it all together and so an
exercise that I thought of originally as
being one of arming ourselves for combat
argument with those who say that
inequality does not matter also has
turned out to be a very valuable
exercise for those who intuitively think
it does matter but may not have really
worked out just why and just in how many
ways I'm going to give you a couple of
examples of what in the book we we
consider to be results of growing
economic inequality in
one has to do with higher education and
it's interesting that that education has
always put forward as the solution by
those who say there's a problem and what
they often ignore is that unfortunately
the educational system is reflecting the
very same pattern of increased
inequality and is therefore often part
of the problem not part of the solution
and here is one illustration of how it
might end up that way the Higher
Education Act of 1965 and a series of
other policies that followed upon it in
policies embraced by Democratic
congresses and Democratic President
Lyndon Johnson and a Republican
President Richard Nixon were explicitly
aimed at reducing the class divide in
higher education grants and loans for
that purpose and this policy worked for
a while it hasn't been working lately
because tuitions have soared
astonishingly and the maximum size as
some of you here in this room may may be
aware the maximum grant available is now
a droplet in the bucket of what it costs
to for a four-year college education and
meanwhile financial assistance both from
the states and from institutions
themselves is more and more being used
to compete for a relatively small pool
of top applicants regardless of their
need so 40 years after the Higher
Education Act the class divide in terms
of enrollment in four-year colleges is
actually widening today it's as wide as
it was 40 years ago having gotten a
little narrower and it's getting wider
even though of course the economic value
of a college degree has gone up
tremendously this is an example of
something you see in another number of
other realms of life where a lot of
Americans actually would like to see a
rough threshold of equality or do not
feel it's a right to have the dollar
rule let's look at our democracy
America of course is proselytizers with
undiminished fervor all over the world
for for democracy meantime the most
important primary is no longer you know
any New Hampshire or Iowa or even Super
Tuesday it's on what's called the wealth
primary the competition to see who can
raise the most money which candidate can
raise the most money in the year before
a presidential election wealth primary
winners have won both major private on
to win both major party nominations
every time out since 1976 with one
interesting exception the one
interesting exception being Howard Dean
who raised his money unconventionally in
smaller amounts the once in office
elected a leaders at that elected
leaders at the federal state and local
level raised huge campaign war chests
and used redistricting powers to keep
potential opponents at bay and here I
have a little quiz for you all
401 members of the House of
Representatives ran for re-election in
2004 how many do you suppose lost 5 5 is
the number that's that's 1% so we had a
99 almost a 99% re-election rate imagine
if that reelection rate were in some
third-world country some you know Middle
East shaked them or somewhere and and
and they claim to be a democracy what
would we be saying so and I just want to
point out that two of them two of those
incumbents who lost lost as a result of
8 a famous or notorious partisan
redistricting plan in Texas so I'm not
sure those two can really be cited as
examples of our vibrant democracy so
there's many much else to say about the
far-reaching effects of inequality but
that gives you an idea thanks Jim
mixed up from United for a fair economy
major Louie well clearly we need a lot
more people outraged by inequality and
the growth of it and so sometimes it's
helpful to look at our own stories how
did we get that outrage I know the
people in this room are outraged well my
story is a lot like what Barbara
Ehrenreich talks about in this book and
in her book nickeled and dimed which is
that women are often one man away from
poverty so I learned about the economy
when I became a single mother and I was
pounding the pavement looking for a job
that fit with my son's daycare schedule
and so on and I found myself knocking at
the door of a Dunkin Donuts in Fall
River Massachusetts the manager
interviewed me and said oh you Chinese
our good workers aren't you so I said I
saw very good sorry but I could see that
he was looking at me like the coyote
looks up you know the the roadrunner
already roasted it on the plate so I got
the job but about six months in the cash
register came up a $24 short and they
docked the girls the counter girls four
of us six dollars a piece
well that really pissed me off I mean
you know it was bad enough you know what
the conditions that I was working under
you know minimum wage etc so I found out
that there was a rule that this was
illegal especially since the supervisor
had also had his money his hand in the
till so I tried to get the other three
counter girls to do it with me
but they wouldn't they were more
interested in staying in good with the
white manager than they were in getting
their $6 back which really surprised me
because you know I would think they
would want their money back but this
little by the way I did win my money
back lost my job but I've got my money
back but this little Dunkin Donuts in a
way is a microcosm of our entire society
so if you look at with the soap opera
going on inside of it as well but if you
look at the whole situation the Dunkin
Donuts is an extremely successful
company their Dunkin Donuts you know
popping up on every street corner like
mushrooms on a rotten log and inside of
it you
had the managers that were paid a
reasonable amount you had the men who
were allowed to be the doughnut makers
the women were not which made me wonder
what special equipment do the men have
to make them then you had the women and
then you had women of color so you have
this racialized and genderized hierarchy
and that exists within our society and
unfortunately in terms of alliances they
don't get made in logical kinds of ways
it is inequality though that really
makes a difference I wouldn't have been
so upset if everybody was treated the
same or if we were all getting the same
amount and some people might still know
folks that live through the depression
they say you know we were poor but we
didn't know we were poor because
everyone was poor and wev Du Bois said
at the about a century ago to be a poor
man is hard but to be a poor race in a
land of dollars is the very bottom of
hardship and actually when you think
about Martin Luther King we always think
about his I have a dream speech
that was not and I have a dream speech
that was his show me the money
speech if you look at that speech it was
about we're here to cash a promissory
note we were promised life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness how can we do
it we're not gonna do it it wasn't about
some fantastic dream and that's why you
United for a fair economy has been
publishing reports for three years now
called state of the dream to see how far
we're coming so let me give you a couple
nerdy things I think because I got to be
like Paul just in terms of the current
picture in terms of income let me just
do this quickly so just to talk about
the progress we looked at income and
whether how much progress had been made
between 1968 the year of Martin Luther
King's death and 2004 we found that the
per capita income of an african-american
in 68 was about 55 cents on the white
persons dollar in 2004 well actually
there was a rise right after the civil
rights movement but then it receded
again in the in the more recent years it
had risen to 57 cents two cents more so
you know if you think we just we
celebrated 50 years of Brown versus
Board of
versus Brown versus Board of Education a
couple years ago and the keywords in
that Supreme Court decision were all
deliberate speed so we figured that it
would at that rate of narrowing
inequality it would take 581 more years
for blacks to reach income parity with
white so that's what all deliberate
speed means in the in this country but
if you look at wealth it's even worse
people have color earned less but they
own far far less the net worth of a
white family right now is about a
hundred and twenty-one thousand dollars
whereas for a black family it's only
nineteen thousand dollars so that's like
you know whites earn nearly twice as
much as blacks but they own nearly
eleven times more than blacks now why
does this make any difference I think in
looking at racial economic inequality
just what you earn is not enough because
I think Ray Bashara from the American
New America Foundation said that income
helps you get by but assets or wealth
help you get ahead so it's really like
if you're just always trying to get
income in order to survive
you're really on a treadmill you're just
running in place but it's only if you
have a little wealth can your family and
community get on that escalator so that
you will start to rise into the middle
class and beyond so just wanted to say
we're what are the myths about why some
people get rich certainly one of the
myths that goes on now is that people of
color are not as wealthy because they
are lazier because they don't work as
hard and that whites are ahead because
they work so hard so back in the earlier
part of the century one of the first
millionaires a millionaire doesn't
really sound like they're that rich
anymore but that was a huge thing it was
john paul Getty the oil magnate or
magnate or whatever you call it it was
one of the first and of course everybody
wanted to know how did you become a
millionaire and he said it's simple I
got three simple things that you have to
follow the first is work hard
everybody said yep I can do that rise
early I can do that
third find an oil well that was his
third thing but you know he never
thud where did I get the land on which
that oil was found if you look at the
history of the United States the
Homestead Act which was a huge wealth
building opportunity for whites and it's
is still the basis of wealth for many
white families in the United States
today the homesteading act was in 1862
right on the heels of many years of the
Indian Wars in which the Indian lands
were were confiscated and supposedly
free land was available for white
families and it was only for white
families and there's a lot of we could
go into the stories of every group that
has been racialized in this country and
there are slightly different ways in
which they have been disadvantaged as a
verb so they are they are not
disadvantaged by themselves but they
were disadvantaged so I think that as we
look at economic inequality we cannot
just look at the whole picture it's bad
enough that it's growing in general but
there has always been a divide an
economic divide between whites and
people of color and that has also been
growing recently and I'll just end with
them just a note about our economy if
you all have a family and you have
several kids and you have your teenaged
boy at the dinner table and you've got a
bowl of mashed potatoes and he takes all
of the mashed potatoes and put him puts
them on his own plate what do you say to
that boy do you say you know you don't
say anything to him and say the little
one what's wrong with you how come you
don't have any mashed potatoes on your
plate
you know do you say like try a little
harder get some mashed potatoes but by
the way don't touch anything don't touch
any of those potatoes on your brother's
plate you know we really have a society
right now that is just doesn't pass the
any sane mother test so it would be
pretty obvious to say you know come on
junior share the damn mashed potatoes
right we're not saying that in this
country right now and it obviously in a
family situation you want everyone to be
healthy you want everyone to eat you
want everyone to have share the
resources of the family you know that
you will be better off if your little
son grows to be strong and as well
so I think just as a country we have to
consider what are the rules that we are
laying down here and to get back onto
the track of sanity thank you
great job thank you well major talked
about it but Paul I'd love you to
respond to the one of the biggest sort
of canards out there in our media you
talked you touched on it as I said miss
you but there is this notion that
inequality is somehow a natural
consequence of the way things are that
there's a free and natural wonderful
market over here and a interfering nasty
artificial government over there how do
you correct that record okay first thing
you say is in that case the the whole
generation after world war ii never
happened there must have been it must
have been a myth the fact of the matter
is that the the the best growth the US
economy has ever had let's let's accept
that gdp is your standard which it
shouldn't be but but just do that in
fact the best growth that the US economy
has ever had was during a period when
with the income distribution was also
the most equal the middle class was
strongest so actually the that whole
period after World War Two was was
amazing success that was in it with with
a relatively by no means entirely but
relatively just society second thing is
you look and say well who are the rich
and how do they get that way and it
actually turns out you know that yes
sure there are you know there's Tiger
Woods and people like that who may have
some something to sell as natural market
forces but an amazingly large share is
people who basically have insider status
and and by the way this is all quite
murky I should say that that one of the
problems we have is that there are small
numbers of because the so much of the
wealth is concentrated in small groups
of people many of the statistics the way
that they're captured don't get it
don't don't actually pick this up there
that's census data percept you'll see
somebody says you know look at well the
US census says such-and-such so US
census data systematically for
well-known reasons missus very high
incomes which means it misses all of the
real action here but we look at and a
lot of it a lot of it is is executive
compensation CEOs and and top five and
that's not a market that's an insider
thing it's
really it's nothing at all about market
forces and we know that there's
essentially no relationship between
executive pay and executive performance
right so there there is nothing in there
about the market about rewards you lay
off the better your salary that's right
no it's actually a willingness to
inflict pain this is definitely a good
but no so yeah so the the point is it's
just we if you have a little sense well
I I had to say I confront this people
saying well doesn't you know it isn't it
always true that as you make progress
that the gap between rich and poor grows
this there's no actually in fact when I
was going to graduate school
30-something years ago we were told that
as countries advance they become more
middle-class and the great disparities
went away and this is something new this
is not the way it has to be this is
something that yeah but I worried that
people to have the one of the things
that might find most frustrating about
situation just I'm talking too long here
but is the ease with which this very
weird and I say unamerican thing that's
happening is becoming accepted as a
natural order of things this is the way
it has to be and it doesn't a to you Jim
we're mocking today the death of Curtis
Scott King and in many of the obituaries
it will be reminded that we will be
reminded that in nineteen in April of 68
she led a march in Memphis right after
dr. King's assassination what we might
not be reminded of is later that very
same year she led a led the poor
people's March in Washington DC it seems
like a long time since we had poor
people's marches like that
Jim in your piece in the book inequality
matters you investigate the question of
our people indifferent so this gap or
are they simply resigned maybe you could
talk about that a little bit and how do
you know pollsters and political
scientists quite a lot of them will tell
you that Americans by nature do not care
about economic differences that it that
we set up
the most successful the people with the
most money as role models rather than
rather than questioning how they got
that much however if you look at a lot
of the things that we clearly do care
about the things that we have active
policy debates over and and come up with
policy solutions for whether the
solutions work or not they turn out to
be problems that have been greatly
aggravated by growing economic
inequality one of the only after we've
produced this book that I realized one
of them which is the the alleged social
security crisis the shortfall in in the
Social Security
you know funds over the next 50 years is
largely the result of the fact that so
much income growth has gone to a tiny
few in America lately that the
percentage of total income that is
captured by the Social Security tax
which ends above what is it now ninety
thousand dollars is has been declining
at once once the Social Security tax
captured ninety percent of all income
now I think it's 85 percent and and that
difference alone accounts for I believe
more than half of this shortfall over
the next 50 years but there are so many
other examples the uninsured being
pretty a pretty graphic one we can call
it a problem of lack of health insurance
or we can call it one aspect of a
problem of a health care system that is
devoting immense resources to the needs
of a relatively well-heeled few and is
confronting everyone else with
skyrocketing skyrocketing costs which
they are increasingly expected to pay
out of their own pockets
it's not impossible to imagine national
health insurance in America coming in a
form that still wouldn't solve this
problem because so many health insurance
plans that so many people have that they
can get leave them with
so many costs uncovered so I think it is
important to see the bigger picture care
are they indifferent to this or are they
big they care about the consequences
it's the word and the abstraction that
people don't care about on on health
insurance this act wasn't before I was
gonna say but this is other 62% the
public says that the government should
guarantee health insurance for everyone
it's one of these things it's what it's
politically impossible to have universal
health insurance and yet it's
politically they did you ask people it's
got overwhelming public support so it's
an odd tells you something about the
nature of political possibility in our
society but I wanna say I think actually
people are I'm not sure how concerned
people are about inequality but I think
they would be more concerned if they
actually knew how big it was and I think
part of the problem this is one of these
things where there's a kind of almost
self reinforcing aspect is that when the
gaps grow really big people lose sight
sort of the ends both ends disappear
into the fog if I can just take a second
two stories one is I had a piece in The
New York Times Magazine three years ago
without any quality and and started the
opening story was about the return of
gigantic mansions for the wealthy and
when you do one of those pieces you
don't see the artwork you don't see the
photos until them out you know I did I
saw them the same time everybody else
did because I and I was never asked and
so that they at the front they had what
the New York Times art department
thought was a picture of a rageous
mansion and it wasn't it was a picture
of actually two blocks from me there's
this nice place and you know that's a I
live in a pretty pretty high-end town
and there was a and that was a three
million dollar or six thousand square
foot house they had that is not what
today's wealthy are building today's
wealthy are building a 60 million dollar
you know 30,000 square foot houses they
are permanent homes yes right and the
art so that so they even even at the New
York Times has no idea how rich the rich
are and at the other end
the other and this was this is something
I'm doing work on health care quite a
lot now and and most of what you know
never makes it into the times but anyway
yeah but I Medicaid Medicaid is
essentially a pub as a program of
medical care for the poor in near poor
and I in my mind thought that as this is
a relatively small group of people that
that you know is there it's a safe dance
relatively small group people Medicaid
is essentially the same size as Medicare
there it says thirty eight million
versus forty million people a huge chunk
of the despite the fact there many
people who should be on Medicaid who are
not getting it the fact is as a and now
I don't know anybody on Medicaid I don't
know anybody who's ever been on Medicaid
for you know sitting in the upper middle
class or so but I think that many
middle-class Americans have never have
no you have no idea I even I with paying
a lot in this had no idea how many
people are essentially you have to be
fairly desperate to be to be pushed onto
Medicaid and I I didn't with all the
time I've spent worrying about these
issue I had no idea just how many people
are in that situation and the budget
that is likely to be voted on tomorrow
or sometime this week is gonna cut
Medicaid for almost all the children on
it and it goes I mean surely the
question of does inequality matter was
writ large in the Gulf when we saw in
New Orleans it mattered whether you
survived or whether you drowned no
absolutely and actually we just put out
a report called stalling the dream which
was about car ownership and it turns out
that in our country which you know
everything supposedly what was good for
General Motors was good for the country
so our whole society's built around
roadways we instead of public
transportation
we spent public dollars on building
highways that you can't use unless you
own a car and it turns out that 7% of
white families don't own cars but 24% of
African Americans 17% of Latino families
don't own cars so we have a wealth gap
in terms of car ownership and in New
Orleans that made a critical difference
and we looked at evacuation plans all
around the city all around the country
and they all depend
on your access to a private car but I
wanted to say one thing - about the
health care issue what do we think is
the largest contributor to the good
health of the nation sanitation systems
clean water right now we spend like 1%
of all the money we spend on health
related stuff on public health and you
know we're talking about terror attacks
and biological weapon we're not prepared
1 percent 99 percent is spent on
treatment or finding out cures and drugs
for some of them quite esoteric diseases
and new and newer and newer technology
so again this is where we're not paying
attention to the Commons
the things that really help people the
most dental care fluorination of the
water was one of the things that really
eliminated dental problems for so many
kids and people in our country so again
we need to invest a lot more and I think
that's part of the solution that we're
pointing to in this book we need to
invest a lot more in the common good in
our in our Commons I just wanted to urge
you to talk a little bit about the
programs that do work you wrote about
one recently the Veterans Health
Administration okay let me just the
thing I couldn't resist coming in on was
that there was actually a major research
effort from the congressional leadership
that was lost immediately after Katrina
actually even before the I think even
before the National Guard actually
arrived finally which was they were it
began desperately searching for someone
anyone who had died in Katrina who was
wealthy enough to owest a text and they
never did find one no no no in order to
manatee to use that that person as a
poster child poster adult for for the
importance of repealing the estate tax I
mean health care look if you had I said
that's very hard to do stuff we we don't
know we don't we haven't we have a rough
notion of how it was that the
middle-class America was created by
Franklin Roosevelt and we don't know how
to replicate those conditions it was a
combination of a very powerful Union
movement which was brought into
existence partly by the New Deal now
wartime conditions which and there was a
lot of sort of
that took place under the war which
which which stuck for for for forty
years don't know how to do that again
things we do know how to do it
Healthcare is it I mean the there's an
enormous it's not exactly it's it's
related to inequality but the riskiness
of of life for Americans is much greater
than that for other advanced countries
and a large part of that is because
you're just one illness away from from
intense poverty and and that's because
we do not have a safety net health care
and this is one of those things where
aside from just the question of helping
people out this is a case of ideology
just totally trumps all the evidence
right now other than that part the drug
the drug thing the every time that
there's been any head-to-head
competition between simple the
government providing the insurance or
introducing private companies as
middlemen government simple government
provision wins hands down that just that
there's enormous saving in paperwork
costs Medicare has been trying to push
these health care Medicare Advantage
plans they're now heavily subsidized
because they cannot compete head-to-head
with just straight Medicare so what they
did with the Medicare drug bill was they
simply you were not allowed to simply
get your insurance from Medicare so they
created a completely gratuitous level of
private companies and it turns out that
a simple canadian-style if you like but
there are other countries that you can
borrow from as well simple national
health care is remarkably cheaper then
then then the the system that the this
fragmented system we have so much so
that if we actually went to national
health care which covered all the
uninsured it would almost certainly be
cheaper in total than our current system
that is the that the cost of covering
all of the uninsured is negative and the
and then it turns out that that worse
yet
which people I guess I've mentioned many
times that the why brought about
sometimes the we actually have one
island of socialized medicine in the
United States which is the Veterans
Administration health care system and it
is wildly efficient it is it it's not
just very cost effective but it turns
out that it actually by all the measures
of health care quality it's the best
system in America and it has low costs
low administrative costs low rates of
medical errors and but I actually I
mentioned I can't tell you who but a a
very well-known pundit and I were in a
green room and we were just sort of
chatting and I mentioned you know II
looked at the VA system it's really
couldn't he actually started screaming
at me an outrage no you're wrong I said
have you looked at the facts no you're
wrong it's a lousy system it's a
government program it's got to be
terrible and that's that's where we are
in this country did his name begin with
a B and then a no that's alright
his name didn't begin with a B and then
a no no no okay I want to just address
two more points one is what stopping
change and the second is what is if we
don't change course and what stopping
change the question comes to me because
if you raise the question of raising the
minimum wage one of the tools we might
have to decrease inequality all across
this country there are majorities
polling in favor of an increase in the
minimum wage you saw in Nevada and
Florida ballot initiatives that raise
the minimum wage by a dollar passed in
every county of those two states rich
poor urban rural conservative liberal
past everywhere against in Florida in
particular the business lobby all out
against it in Utah I was just in Utah
the last state to give George Bush
really healthy approval ratings when
it's polled on the question of minimum
wage increased 67 percent of those
polled wanted an increase and to spend
that budget surplus on that increase
rather than any more in the way of tax
cuts who is stopping change why is it so
difficult to make change on something as
simple as that
Jim you want to start right first of all
it does have something to do with the
fact that all the institution
that we would normally look to to give
us a clear view of what is going on have
themselves been colored by this growing
economic inequality so Paul said earlier
that maybe if the story was more fully
told if people knew how bad it was there
would be more anger I think that's true
I think that if the connection were made
between growing economic inequality and
diminished opportunity that would make a
big difference if they wanted they the
people wanted
that's the legislators who keep wanting
to talk about tax cuts people who
support tax cuts according to some some
polling never make any connection
between that and some change in the
overall distribution of wealth power and
income in America they have no idea that
these tax cuts might feed that they
don't think of it in those terms the
great the the paper on on this whole
subject by mr. Krugman is colleague and
Larry Patel had the the title Homer gets
a tax cut and you shows someone looking
very like Homer Simpson holding a check
for you know fifty cents and smiling
delightedly but I don't with mr. burns
next in with bags but I just want to say
I think that the free-market ethos and
the belief that there is such a thing as
a free market is has us in its grip more
than any other people and perhaps more
than us at this time more than any other
time and that it is to some extent a
relic of the Cold War when it made a
certain sense as a view of the world to
see our Western market economies as a
free market and you know the the Soviet
system as unfree but the fact is that
markets to be functioning to be
successful they cannot be free they must
have rules and social norms and
institutions and enforcement mechanisms
and these rules this whole system has
changed dramatically in recent decades
and it isn't entirely a matter of policy
changes although there are plenty of
those
to look at and we there essays in the
book to talk about that it's also as
Paul Krugman says it's a matter of
social norms and you see cases in which
for example the taft-hartley law made it
possible to fire to replace strikers
with permanent replacement workers but
it took corporate America and America as
a whole 20 or 30 years to actually
exercise that that right that
taft-hartley gave them so if this free
market idea which is so powerful in
America is one that is a paralyzing idea
it makes you think there is no reason to
think about the level of economic
inequality because there is nothing we
can do about it and when you don't think
about something it's human nature not to
look too closely at it not to look at
the consequences so it becomes a whole
vicious circle which is fed by the media
and other institutions that you know
yeah what's stopping change I think the
Democrats for one thing there's an
actually an article in this book that
talks about how in countries where there
are more political parties you're likely
to have more equality because working
people lower-income people are more
likely to have a voice in a coalition
'el type of government so we live in a
country that can't count past - I never
could quite figure out why - is more
democratic than say three or maybe four
but it's just you know either with us or
with the enemy
the other thing is that there is really
a conscious mystification of the economy
and what's going on so that people are
made stupid I was talking with Amy Wroe
who I think is it who we were talking
about how people are kind of made stupid
so for example we're constantly told we
have a jobless recovery like this is
great but it's an oxymoron you know for
if you don't have a job how is it a
recovery
but if you're told this over and over
again you're thinking like by experts
right you're thinking like I must be
stupid cuz I really don't get this I
know I don't have a job but so I think a
lot of our job is too too deep you know
to take apart these myths and to really
let people see what's going on one of
the things we do at United for a fair
economy is that we noticed that a lot of
people were really outraged by service
cuts but they were still voting for tax
cuts so by helping to them to make that
connection is a way that we can really
get way that we can really get people to
understand the policies that drive their
own economic inequality I'm just
surprised that neither of my co-panelist
is just talking about the raw influence
of money in politics is that I mean I
know I haven't looked at the minimum
wage politics but I did a little bit and
was paying a lot of attention to
Elizabeth Warren's work on the
bankruptcy bill which which is a is a
monstrosity but was passed with I'm
sorry to say wide bipartisan support and
you look behind that and it's money it's
it's it's the power of a lobby it's a
certain talkative Democratic senator
suddenly stopped being the senator from
Delaware and became the senator for MBA
and it's all Wellstone single-handedly
stopped it in one session
that's right died ya know one with his
courage and it was it was truly and this
was not certainly not that the Senate
was unaware in everything that the
intellectual arguments have been made
and then laid out there was no not a
that the credit card companies barely
even tried to make a rational economic
case for the bill they just sort of
spread the money and and it's it was one
of the more depressing things to watch
you could make you a complete cynic
about the system so the last question is
you you mentioned that that we had net
we have as a country not been this in
equal unequal um since 1929
that's always a date that he sticks in
the mind what happens if we don't change
direction Paul then Jim man made sure
I'd like it would be nice it would be
sort of
a good morality play if in fact the
twenty nine thing was was you know if
that meant that disaster strikes just
over the horizon it's I'm not I'm not
sure I mean it's not clear that the
Great Depression was necessary you know
follow on on on the inequalities of
American society it's not it would be
nice if that were if that were true but
but economics is not a morality play
that doesn't so it's possible you can
struggle along like this for a very long
time what does happen is it does start
to impair it's it's of course there are
a lot of things first of all just a lot
of people are miserable it becomes a
worse and a meaner society and and I
think in the end you these actually the
by the by by having people increasingly
just left out of the system it actually
it actually ends up in the end maybe
even making some other rich worse off I
guess the thing that worries me most
aside from just the sort of ongoing
human misery but put all that on one
side the real question about democracy
when you have well there I can't I don't
have my Theodore Roosevelt quotes
exactly to my my fingertips but
something about if there are if there
are men who are rich enough to own the
government they will this that this is
the problem it is as we start to look an
income distribution like a like a third
world country maybe we start to have the
politics of a third world country and
that's that's I think all the the
gravest danger Jim I take comfort from
the fact that as deformed as our
democracy is that many of the policies
that have fed this growing inequality
were not laid out there in the open on
the contrary there was a tremendous
investment over several decades in the
creation of think tanks and journals and
the the hiring of of wordsmiths and and
all kinds of young whiz kids to come up
with a whole vocabulary of justifying
these policies that made them see
to be for all our good the the the
examples you know the estate taxes the
death is an estate tax that in truth
effects a tiny tiny number of the
richest estates is characterized as a
death tax that threatens family farms
and small businesses and as far as I
know they're never able to come up with
a family harm or a small business and
the tax relief for all Americans is the
euphemism for the tax cuts for the few
so forth and so on all of this
subterfuge all of the massive investment
of propaganda what what accounts for it
why was it deemed necessary it can only
be that somebody somewhere thought that
if Americans really understood what was
going on they they wouldn't go for it
and I and that if they raised a cry of
protest that things would change and I
think there's a lot of reason to think
that things would change because they've
changed in societies with far less
democracy than we have if Americans
weren't divided one from the other
nation just quickly I mean I think that
with Paul in terms of democracy and Jim
that democracy is like a muscle if you
don't exercise it it will atrophy and
just as we're sort of we've become an
obese nation in terms of our physical
we're also obese in terms of our
democracy and I think that people don't
realize that it isn't you can't take it
for granted you can lose it and in the
United States we're very complacent
because again we're told over and over
again this is the most democratic
country in the world blah blah blah and
people believe it but they look they
will lose it if they don't actually
exercise democracy by learning about
what's going on by exercising their
critical thinking and making policies
that are for the benefit of the nation
as a whole because united we stand and
divided we will fall
we have a little time before the end of
the program which is when you all - to
the back and buy the books or no to the
front and buy the books and we'll sign
them so if you want to raise a question
come up to this microphone and I want to
see women and men and anybody else sir I
want to thank you all for your positions
on what where we're at right now but I
have a one thing I haven't heard in 45
minutes here the effect of what the war
has done on this economy good question
the war the war is milking us dry on
every aspect I'd like to hear your
comments on that and how can we get out
of it because it was it's been wrong
from day one it continues and nothing's
happening nothing's happening really and
number two
Paul dealing with the issue of the VA
hospitals you are absolutely correct but
this administration wants to cut back on
the VA hospitals they have been holding
the cares lap hearings which in turn
they want to even merge Brooklyn and
Manhattan on 23rd Street or even close
them down all right thanks let's take
three questions so one the impact of the
war and what about the hospitals to you
that Mike okay that's an iconic question
to dr. Krugman I can insane salaries of
CEOs be simply explained by the lack of
diffusion tools
I mean if exploitation is less such as
if people don't work 80 hours instead of
40 and are paid only for if they're a
mandatory vacation which don't allow all
these tools which don't allow
accumulation in one corner office and
just spread around a journalist which is
done who are the countries European
countries can you just explain are there
are other tools to address the
inequality executive compensation and
worker compensations that the question
yes all right good last one and then
we'll take answers I'd like to speak to
the fact that our trade international
trade is in a pretty bad situation and I
wonder how much the fact that companies
have to include health care in the cost
of their products leads to our being
less competitive in the international
market
great question all right we've got three
questions let's get some answers who
wants to address the question of the war
what difference does a war make Jim I
take one tack on that which is that Paul
spoke about the danger of our democracy
becoming or our country becoming more
like a third world Society our politics
and one of the ways in which we may
experience that process is the eye is
the pattern of going to war when times
are tough
domestically yeah let me just I was I
was against the war from the beginning
and I think it's a nightmare for even
quite from everything so everyone knows
it's just been a terrible blow to u.s.
national security I think you don't want
to make it the root of all evil and the
fact is that this this trend of growing
inequality long predates the Iraq war
the Iraq war is big by any normal human
standards but the US economy is immense
and the war is it is is about a third of
a percent of of gross domestic no it's
two-thirds of a percent of gross
domestic product now is going into the
war that's sort of a third of Vietnam
it's it's not it's not a huge story here
it's a it's a horrible thing it doesn't
it but it's not it's not this story so I
think just you know that this is III I
don't know when that may never be able
to know how much was conscious was
certainly true that if you were to ask
in in the summer of 2002 it appeared
that we might be getting some genuine
populist outrage over
corporate scandals over the whole
inequality and then all of a sudden the
drumbeat of war completely silenced that
I don't know if that's it it how much
how much you want to say that that was
deliberate and how much it's just how it
happened but it certainly it certainly
has worked our politics these past three
years major did you want to answer that
question no maybe the one about
executive compensation you know just to
say that in terms of the the war it's
one of the it's the only time in United
States history where there has not been
shared sacrifice in that the cost of the
war is borne by low-income people as is
the fighting of the war and and the
wealthy companies have benefited so it's
another example of how the divide is
grown yeah just about about the
executive compensation in France were in
Germany which everybody know you know
they have their own problems they don't
have our problems they have different
problems but but in France or Germany
you have powerful unions you have you
have parties of the left that actually
set up all of which means that their
outrage constraint binds a lot more
tightly than then it binds the way it
used to in the United States and so they
are continuing to pay top executives
roughly the way the American top
executives were paid in the 1960s 40
times typical worker salary you know
that by no means impoverished but and
and this they what's happened in the
United States is that we have somehow
lost all of the countervailing power all
the countervailing voices the people who
can say my god why is this guy who has
actually been running the company into
the ground being paid thirty million
dollars a year somehow lost as in trade
unions smashed into that certainly the
the collapse of the of the private
sector unions in United States is a big
part of the story they were pushed yes
on the question of health care and the
ability to compete it was interesting
the Ford company chose to chose to shut
down 14 plants and announced the layoffs
of 30,000 over a few years I only found
out on my radio program which is
weekends on our America Radio 1190
that a lot of the work was being
transferred not to developing nations
but to Canada where a worker is $10
cheaper an hour because of the
healthcare button it's one of my one of
the enduring mysteries if you go the the
Big Three automakers are also the Big
Three automakers in Canada in Canada
they are ferocious defenders of Canadian
Medicare the National Health System they
say and they and they write letters to
say to to the government saying you
mustn tamper with this is a crucial
aspect of Canadian industrial
competitiveness and in the United States
why aren't they advocating such a system
here and we wonder and you keep on and
you read some of the speeches by
particularly by a by Wagner the CEO of
the General Motors and you keep the
sight and the last line of this column
is going to be a call for a single-payer
health care suspending ever says it and
we are question is is this easy to just
be afraid afraid of being blackballed at
the Country Club what's going on here
okay three more questions and that's
probably going to be it we can't have
all three men so let's have 103 we'll
make it four we'll have you as well okay
one two three four go comments yeah I
think we're leaving a corporate
oligarchy and sound bites and and just a
very quick short story and then a
question which is I go down to a small
mountain town every year for a music
festival and I'm and rather intelligent
guy we go into a breakfast place and
what they see of the news is a little
bit on TV and that's about it
now people like you Paul and marine I
love always read your columns you're
you're saying the truth but so the
question of two questions one is how can
the truth reach the vast the majority of
quotation marks middle America and why
the hell isn't the press and it's not
not people like you but like getting out
there
and giving the message are they part of
the problem too
professor Krugman if if the outrage
constraints no longer working
do you support in theory regulation to
try to disincentivize excessive
compensation for executives question and
then two over there yes my friend and I
were musing the other day about how we
will talk about the most intimate
secrets of our social lives or our
family lives of our sex lives but nobody
talked about money and that there's this
thing about money and especially among
like upper middle class white sort of
guilt Laden yeah
that sort of happens for people um and I
know that you this is direction this
direction up mrs. Liu United for a fair
economy was doing some work with
directed at wealthier Americans who
wanted to change and I'd love for you to
hear about that work and well more all
right you're all being great they're all
being great go for it we spoken a lot
this evening about social norms and what
effect the social norms have on the
mentality that most Americans have about
the inequality that pervades this
society but dr. Cornel West wrote two
books one culture matters and the other
race matters and specifically addressing
this issue when are we as Americans
gonna just wake up and say you know what
I'm a part of the disenfranchised and
I'm a part of the problem and I need to
do something about it we should thoughts
thanks yeah
this is for professor Krugman I'm more
concerned about the increase in wealth
inequalities than in income inequalities
and that does seem to be very much
fostered by a public policy we've always
had much more disparity income
inequalities than other advanced Western
countries
a measure like the Gini coefficient were
disastrously behind almost all other
advanced societies but we were pretty
far behind them in 1980 and it hasn't
really changed that much I'm not sure
you know what on the top end isn't being
captured I think it is somewhat more an
80/20 than 99 one problem because if the
median changes 10% one standard
deviation or moved from the median is
37% and two standard deviations removed
is 120 that's it for questions go
every time someone seems to propose
something in Congress or elsewhere that
would address even one aspect of this
inequality issue this administration
shouts it down as class warfare so I
want to know what we can do to make
class warfare a good thing
I knew you were the right person to end
the program all right we've got a bunch
of questions there how can the truth
break through our kind of soundbite
culture how can we disincentivize
inequality what are we doing to talk
about class we don't we'll talk about
sex before we'll talk about money what
about all the divisions can we come
together to see ourselves as one boat
going down rather than it's always some
poor persons I'm darker skinned person
some female person or increasingly
somebody from another country that's
their problem
wealth inequality versus income
inequality and how can we spin positive
on class warfare who wants to pick up
pick pick pick one or two and respond
start with you Jim we start with the
question about a regulation a limit on
CEO pay or something like that I don't
really want to try to address and I
don't even know my own convictions about
the merits of such a regulation but I
just want to say that in the real world
I don't think you're gonna get
regulation when the outrage quotient
isn't very high in the real world I
think regulation of something like that
is going to come when the outrage
quotient is high so raising
consciousness is necessary element of
all this raising the outrage quotient
and there are possibilities there are
glimpses of potential in this audience
right here in this book in this program
being on c-span in the fact that the New
York Times The Wall Street Journal the
Los Angeles Times all within the last
year have run large ambitious really
well done series on declining mobility
the increased kind of stress and
volatility and insecurity that affects
the middle class the I like to think
that that instead of being a country
divided between those who think that
inequality does not matter and those who
think it does that we are all on a
journey
and we're at various stages of the
realization of how much it does matter
hmm just a couple quick things in terms
of some ways of exposing what's going on
in 2000 we had a sort of a project that
was called billionaires for bush or Gore
and there's a great chapter here in New
York that always has demonstrations on
tax day in front of the post office and
so on and so forth but you know whoever
Bush was campaigning there would be a
crowd of people that was dressed like
rich people with their signs you know
because the inequality is not growing
fast enough and it would take the bush
people a while to figure out that these
were behind the enemy lines that way so
it was that was really fun so I think
like finding those kinds of things and
of course the media would zero in on
that remember during the Republican
convention it was the billionaires for
bush playing croquet in Central Park
that got all the media attention because
you you know there was no demonstrations
but people playing croquet in Central
Park you know that was that was cool
in terms of just the responsible wealth
project too I think we've always found
in and do feel that there is room for
everyone it's not about just poor people
if it was just poor people talking about
inequality nobody would care nobody
would pay attention and we do need
allies it's got to be a big movement
just as in the civil rights movement you
had many white people you had wealthy
people that were funding it and so on
but I think the important thing is that
people with wealth don't just have money
and sometimes we stereotype them as like
that's what they have to contribute no
they have their voices to give to so for
instance Bill Gates senior he didn't
give us a lot of money but what he did
in opening up that conversation about
the estate tax was far more valuable and
I think that the estate tax probably
would be repealed now if he had not
spoken out against it and opened up all
of people's consciousness in terms of
the question of like coming together I
think this country still has not faced
the question of the racial divide
head-on and it's like today people don't
want to talk about it's like a thing of
the past and I think that we need to
continue especially white people to talk
with other white people too about the
importance of recognizing
advantages that white people have had
and it's not to make you feel guilty
it's just to say these are the policies
that were put in place over a number of
centuries that benefited you what are
the policies we can put in place today
to close that gap about Gini
coefficients no basically basically the
answer is no it's it's it's not true
that the US has always been more unequal
than others but not to this extent and
it's a drastic change over the past 25
years and it is really it's about a very
very top end and as these are not small
numbers we're not people you say well
you know what does it matter if it's a
little bit more than we're actually
talking about huge redistribution to
people at the very very top of the
income distribution this is not a small
thing whoever the person was read
Paquette ii and Saez it's it's it's
really this this is not this is not
something that's a marginal concern it's
the core of the story and just i think i
can take two things together press and
what you can do why is the press and we
are getting better stories on but
certainly on a lot of issues wonder
where is the press why isn't it covering
and from where I would sit where I sit I
would say a large part of it is sheer
intimidation you have no idea what it's
like if you cross the dominant political
movement these days it's it's it's not
just you know of course enormous
quantities of mail that that needs to be
picked up with tongs but but it's
organized attempts to to undermine you
to find things that to discredit you
know you become a target and most people
in in the media become very afraid of
that and they internalize it they steer
clear of it it's a it's a sad thing but
it's true and of course this is my
secret is I have another job the the
and and and what you can do about it is
actually counter-pressure
the countervailing forces it because I
have seen a number of instances now in
which mobilised people on the moderate
left sort of go after in you know
inaccurate press reporting on stories
and and the press people are hysterical
because they thought they'd found the
way to play it safe and then they've
discovering oh it's not safe to uh sort
of accept untruths from one side so that
they won't they won't scream at us
because there's now starting to be an
organized constituency that will scream
at us and but it it has its effect you
can watch the subsequent reporting and
it gets better that's not just the press
you should also scream at your
Congressman is premature you know but
the but this is certainly it it matters
a lot to to it the this going back to
Jim talking about the organization of
the bad ideas that there was a whole
Machine set in place to influence press
coverage to influence the intellectual
client injury influence the buzzwords
that was set up beginning in the 1970s
and I myself I did not understand until
a couple years ago just how how all of
this but now we're very much behind the
curve but there is you make change the
debate by and part of it involves
screaming at the messengers who are not
we're not conveying the truth so if we
promise to flood your bosses with
applause will you write a column Kloss
well good oh I think I've done that yes
but nobody positive never mind a
positive when when when some when some
journalist especially not the the
opinion journalist but the when there's
a story that is allegedly just a
reporting story that has got it wrong
you know send the negative mail uh make
that make it send the negative emails
and phone calls you'd be amazed how how
freaked people get because they've
they've they've acclimated the view that
you only get that kind of pressure from
the right and it's they're they're
startled and initially outraged but
eventually affected when it's done comes
from the other side I want to thank
everybody and everybody here you've got
your marching orders
the people at demos United for a fair
economy and the new press thank you for
coming stay tuned for more information
and there are books at the front that
can be signed